AND IT'S RIGHT BAC, THROUGH
TO HERTL, AND --
>>E
ISLANDERS GET THE OPENING GOAL
HERE IN TH
JUST LIKE THAT BONINO, AND SORO
IN, MADE
POWER PLAY BARABANOV TO GET
HIS HEAD UP.
CAPTURE RELEASE WITH THE SCREEN
TRAFFIC IN NET, IT
DEFLECTS IN, AND IT'S 2-1
SHARKS VIEL, CROSSING IN FRONT
OFt POINT, BARABANOV, BACK
TO COUTURE
AND OUT FOR DZINGEL, AND
TRYING TO BANK IT IN
AFTER WAHLSTRO
DOBSON, HERE'S CIZIKAS
REIMER DIVESD IT'S 2-2, THAT'S h
STRAIGHT PASS, DOESN'T WASAS
LOGAN
HE KNOWS WHERE TO FIND HOLES ON
PLAYERS COMING OUT ON HIM.
THIS IS A GOOD THOUGHT I
AN IMPRESSIVE RESPONSE BY THN TS
THAT ONE SHOT.
BARZAL, WEAVING THROUGH THE  PAO
THE NET, ANDA SECONDARE SHARKS
HOPING THEY CAN CAPITALIZE.
BARZAL, A CLEAN LANE Th,HE
GETTING THE SCORINNELSON, ONE OF
THE ISLANDER GOALS, HERE'S
NELSON, ON THE AND
REIMER, WITH A BURNS
CHASING BEHIND H
PALMIERI, PAGEAU AGAINST HERTL
THE SHOT AND REIMER' GOT DOBSONE
HITS THE POST.
THAT'S TWO POSTS IHIGH, AND THAT
WILL DO IT FOR THE SECONONE ACC,
REIMER SPEEDS UP WITH HIM AND
DOESN'T BITE ON THAT FIRST MOVE
RIGHT THERE, AND MAKES THE BLOCE
AND HE RIGHT
AND JUST PUTS IT ON TH SHOOTOUTS
NOT THERE FOR BARZAL
HE'S REALLY SHIFTY WITH THE  HEL
AND A GREAT SAVE B